let's get right into audience questions
today first one
is about the so-called secret trump
voters hey david i keep hearing about
shy or secret trump voters sometimes
called the silent majority
is this really a thing do the polls not
understand or account for
trump voters who simply aren't willing
to say they are going to vote for trump
so listen in broad strokes
the answer is that the secret trump
voters don't really exist
there are people who point to 2016 and
they say look the polls were so
wrong people clearly weren't telling
pollsters that they were planning to
vote for donald trump
because they felt some kind of public
shame or they were embarrassed or
whatever the case may be
the polls were basically right in 2016.
hillary was winning by three in the
popular vote she won by 2.2
um these states like i believe that
there was one state that really was
wrong but for the most part the
battleground states that were close
the margins of error were accounting for
the actual results
so 2016 doesn't really give us evidence
that there were secret trump voters the
idea being they hide their preference
from
pollsters until they actually go out
and vote a big difference between 2016
and 2020 is that i don't
know why someone
would be particularly unwilling to admit
today
that they plan to vote for trump in a
poll remember this
your family you know your friends
nobody's going to find out how you voted
in a poll a lot of the polls now are
completely automated so it's not even
that you might be embarrassed
to tell the pollster that you're
planning on voting for trump there
really would be no reason why
if i get a poll and says this is you
know ssrs
uh press one if you plan to vote for
biden plus press two if you plan to vote
for trump
why would i be shy about just answering
truthfully there
the only argument that could be made
would be trumpists have
coordinated to claim they are voting for
biden
in order to give biden a lead in the
polls
which will motivate more trump voters to
get out and vote in november
it's a complete argument you know it's a
post hoc
argument made to justify something we
don't actually have evidence for
and it makes no sense to me whatsoever
there were no you know uh there's no
evidence that there were there are more
shy trump voters than there were shy
obama voters or shy hillary clinton
voters or whatever
certainly there is a significant
cultural divide in this country where
there could be social stigma at work
from being one of the few trump voters
if you work at some tech firm in austin
texas a state that's likely to go to
trump but austin is much more blue
maybe you might not tell your co-workers
that you're going to vote for donald
trump but why would you lie in a poll
your co-workers would never know that so
my sense is it's not so much that what
could turn the election would be
that trump has way more support than the
polls say because of secret trump voters
what's more likely to me is that there
is a part of the base
that doesn't get involved until election
time and
maybe they are more prevalent on the
republican side than the democratic side
maybe joe biden's support is fully
represented in the polls
but some trump support is still sitting
out there as un
i don't know or third party or whatever
because people aren't necessarily paying
attention yet
or whatever the case may be i'm still
manning the argument
i suspect that that would be a small
portion of the electorate
and i don't imagine that you are going
to see any significant
amount of shy trump supporters
or reticent or maybe embarrassed trump
supporters who are going to vote for
trump in november
but for one reason or another are lying
to pollsters today
last thought the other argument is it's
not that there
are shy trump supporters
it's that trump supporters are
skepticals of polls skeptical of polls
so they opt out
well the polls are normalized and
adjusted to make sure that the samples
are representative if you were
imagine that you had trouble getting
trump supporters
to respond because they hate pollsters
and so you would think oh well you're
under-representing trump supporters
trump supporters in the poll no you just
adjust
and normalize the sample to account for
that and pollsters have a number of
different methods that are
scientifically statistically acceptable
in that case
if we're wrong then we will know very
very soon
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you fifteen
percent off
when you go to davidpakman.com
cuts that's c-u-t-s because
solid color t-shirts are a really
important staple in pretty much every
guy's wardrobe
i think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company
all they deal with are men's solid color
t-shirts so they actually put a ton of
thought into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really
the most comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great
this right here that i'm wearing on
youtube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt
very soft fits me perfectly it's the
ideal length go take a look at what they
offer and once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15
percent off when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s